[Música]
al término del mar reciente congreso del
partido comunista en China el país
asiático parece haber sentado las bases
de lo que será el futuro o al menos la
proyección del que es considerado el
gigante asiático por supuesto este
futuro y también las bases que lo van a
sostener recaen tal parece en una sola
persona el actual presidente shejing
ping quien fue reelecto como secretario
general del comité central del partido
comunista Pero la idea del país que
tiene el presidente ha sido conseguida
gracias a la mano dura a minimizar otras
facciones dentro del mismo partido y a
darle continuidad a mantener a la
economía como la espina dorsal para que
china cumpla sus metas y sus objetivos a
nivel internacional veamos
[Aplausos]
aseguró un histórico tercer mandato como
presidente de China un hecho sin
precedentes que vino acompañado de un
nuevo comité permanente del poliguró un
órgano de 7 miembros que constituye la
cúpula de liderazgo de la formación si
también fue reelegido como secretario
general del congreso del partido
comunista de China y presidente de la
comisión militar central del partido
estamos dando pasos confiados en un
nuevo viaje para convertir a China en un
país socialista moderno en todos los
aspectos para avanzar hacia la meta del
segundo siglo y abrazar El Gran
rejuvenecimiento de los chinos en todos
los frentes a través de un camino hacia
la modernización las nuevas caras de la
cúpula china son liquian quien supervisó
como mano de hierro los estrictos
confinamientos en Shanghai una política
cuya continuidad fue reiterada por el
presidente chip se perfila como el
posible próximo Primer Ministro kayquian
ex alcalde de Beijing y encargado de
supervisar la organización de los Juegos
Olímpicos de invierno
fue el secretario de Shanghai y el jefe
de gabinete del mandatario Chino
mientras que lichi saltó varios puestos
hasta llegar al cargo del influyente
organismo en corrupción del partido
los cuatro funcionarios son mayores de
60 años y aliados cercanos de chim y es
la primera vez en 25 años que el comité
no cuenta con la presencia de mujeres el
presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin y el
líder norcoreano Kim Hyun felicitaron a
She por su tercer mandato ambos
esperando incrementar la cooperación
bilateral con la segunda Economía del
mundo
entonces así las cosas dos ideas para
analizar a lo largo de este programa La
primera después de este congreso salió
aún más fortalecido y su reelección le
dará tiempo para cumplir sus planes Qué
significa entonces para China y para el
mundo la continuidad de
El mando de este país asiático y una
segunda idea Cuáles serán Entonces los
pasos que va a dar china a nivel
internacional son muy claras algunas de
las intenciones en algunos Campos pero
en otras no tanto por ejemplo va a
seguir china del lado de Rusia en una
guerra que parece prolongarse en el
tiempo estamos hablando de la guerra en
Ucrania también se pregunta uno si
intentará bajar las tensiones con
Estados Unidos y algunos de sus países
vecinos y cómo va a ser la relación con
América Latina sin duda alguna este
congreso del partido comunista que le
permitió al presidente continuar en el
poder representa un nuevo capítulo en la
historia de china porque se pregunta uno
será la consolidación de una doctrina
vamos a analizarlo entonces en el
programa y para conversar sobre este
tema hemos invitado a Francisco Javier
aro él es experto en etnicidad y
políticas internacionales chinas así
como las relaciones entre Medellín y
América Latina punto que vamos a
analizar en este programa y también está
con nosotros el doctor Jorge Malena Él
es director del postgrado en estudios
sobre China de la Universidad Católica
Argentina ustedes nuestros televidentes
les recuerdo también hacen parte de este
programa pueden dejar todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales ya lo saben estamos
en Twitter también en Facebook y en
instagram nos encuentran como arroba el
debate_f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen sus
comentarios numeral el debate f24 todo
pegado también les recuerdo que todos
nuestros contenidos del programa están
disponibles en podcast estamos en
diferentes plataformas para que ustedes
nos busquen en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
Pues muy bien Le doy entonces la
bienvenida a Francisco Javier aro para
comenzar Este programa Punto de partida
que es la primera pregunta que hago para
conocer las posiciones de los invitados
Francisco Gracias por estar con nosotros
y como hemos dicho en la promo de este
programa un que Tal parece que quiere
ser eterno Busca perpetuarse en el poder
esto significa un nuevo capítulo un
parteaguas en la historia de China su
reelección Y qué es lo que estaría
buscando
bien pues muchísimas gracias por la
invitación primero que nada
lo que me gustaría
Es que tratáramos de explicar el Porque
si hace eso que lo motiva que percibe no
siempre está claro en las explicaciones
en los análisis que leemos muchas veces
se tiende a personalizar sobre algunas
de sus características algunos de sus de
sus comportamientos pero más allá de que
pudiera existir es estos aspectos
conductuales
yo creo lo más importante es que llegó
un momento en la historia de China desde
la perspectiva de las élites chinas pero
también en la contraparte las élites
estadounidenses que el desarrollo de la
economía mundial del desarrollo de las
relaciones entre estos dos países
necesitaba cambiar por un lado
creo que estamos en un proceso de
expectativas no cumplidas de
expectativas
entre las cuales nadie se encuentra
satisfecho
china anual no hay no ha llegado a donde
quisieran las élites norteamericanas no
tendría por qué ser así no ha sido así y
por otra parte los chinos llegó el
momento en que dijeron el mundo tiene
que cambiar las instituciones
internacionales tiene que cambiar la
forma de ejercer el poder tiene que
cambiar y tenemos que estar ahí yo creo
que ese es el problema fundamental si la
voluntad en la búsqueda de la élite
china por convertirse
sino en el hegemon global 100 un hegemon
que comparta con otros hegemones
el poder Ese es el fundamental china
claro concluyó es está
para la guerra quiero aclarar dos cosas
el que un poder se prepara para la
guerra no quiere decir que quiere ir a
la guerra o que vaya a ir a la guerra
Sí ahora continuamos con nuestro
siguiente invitado doctor Jorge para
complementar esta respuesta en doctor
Jorge Gracias por estar con nosotros
allí en la ciudad de Buenos Aires los
saludo y la misma pregunta como Punto de
partida que estaría buscando a través de
esta prolongación de su mandato muchos
dicen que busca perpetuarse allí en el
poder
Buenas tardes Santiago un gusto dialogar
contigo y con el colega bueno
básicamente mi lectura guarda relación
con el hecho de que
existin está consolidando su poder a
partir de lo que es la constitución de
una facción propia y preeminente dentro
del partido comunista de China si bien
desde la década postdanguista
hicieron dos facciones y él mismo ha
sido parte de una de ellas el
Aparentemente decidió especialmente
desde el año 2018 una vez que promovió
una reforma constitucional que le dio la
cabida al inicio de esta segunda
reelección fortalecerse en el poder y
luego como hemos visto la semana pasada
tomar esta instancia del vigésimo
Congreso Nacional del partido comunista
para poner una suerte de acólitos
adeptos hombres fuerte del partido a su
alrededor por eso mi lectura es que en
materia de política internacional
esta concentración de poder Más allá de
consolidación del poder guardaría
entonces relación con marcar un rumbo
que tiene que ver con su cosmovisión
sobre cuál es el mundo y cuál es el
lugar que china debería ocupar en ese
mundo Jorge continuó con usted para
hacer la ronda la inversa Quiero
preguntarle por este tema que usted toca
al final de su respuesta y es el equipo
principal que ha conformado el
presidente personas leales muy cercanas
a él en una especie de limpieza que hizo
de estas altas esferas del partido
comunista esto como se puede leer Cómo
se puede entender al interior del
partido y lo que se espera de las
decisiones que pueda tomar entonces este
nuevo equipo principal que está
completamente
cercano y alineado con la visión que
tiene chigging ping de lo que tiene que
ser China y su papel en el mundo bueno
básicamente las dos facciones
preexistentes se caracterizaban en el
caso de la llamada facción de Shanghai
por su priorización de la Reforma
económica casualmente el anterior
presidente chimín el primer líder post
de enguista que el principal
representante de esta facción luego se
encontraba la otra facción llamada de la
liga juvenil comunista liderada por
Justin Tao quien casualmente fue el
presidente que sucedió a chancemin que
no priorizaba la reforma económica sino
que más bien priorizaba prestar atención
a los efectos no deseados de dicha
reforma Como por ejemplo la
contaminación ambiental la corrupción la
afectación de las condiciones de los
trabajadores por lo tanto entonces surge
ahora el interrogante de cuál va a ser
esta postura del sismo que surge tras
este vigésimo congreso si tomamos
algunos de los puntos más relevantes de
lo que fue el discurso depin al cierre
del décimo noveno congreso podríamos ver
que en cierta medida hay un racismo por
parte de él porque ha tomado algunos
conceptos de su facción de la facción de
Shanghai pero también ha tomado otros
que son los de la liga juvenil comunista
Francisco le doy la palabra usted ahora
en México para para conocer su opinión
sobre este tema sobre este equipo
principal muy cercano al presidenteen la
lectura que se hace desde occidente
sobre todo desde analistas en materia
económica Es que la preferencia que ha
mostrado el presidente por tener lealtad
versus competencias o conocimiento
tecnócrata sobre los temas económicos
puede jugar en contra del panorama
económico que está presentando el país
sobre todo por la coyuntura mundial que
es bastante complicada esto le puede
jugar al presidente en contra y quiero
conocer su opinión sobre esta
conformación de este equipo tan cercano
al presidente Yo creo que
si soy coherente con con mi pensamiento
Es lo que necesita es una maquinaria que
haga que todo todos los engranajes
funcionen en ese sentido
efectivamente hay una nueva etapa una
etapa donde termina una forma de
transmisión del poder
se está cierto tiempo el no va a ser así
una etapa Donde había cierta
institucional de cierta
institucionalización Perdón se
fortalecía el nacimiento de cierto tipo
de instituciones y con él ha cambiado no
podemos predecir exactamente cómo va a
evolucionar todo el proceso pero no yo
creo que no hay que menospreciar el
las las prioridades que que tiene el
secretario general sí y no son
contrapuestas al crecimiento económi Yo
creo que por ejemplo una de las noticias
que que anduvo circulando mucho el día
de hoy ha sido la de El incremento de
las exportaciones de vehículos Y esa es
una industria clave en en el futuro de
las economías del mundo muy por encima
de Japón y de otros países en fin la
economía china enfrenta muchas
dificultades
la que tienen que ver con cuestiones
energéticas
muchas de ellas asociadas a la política
de cero tolerancia acoi-19 pero yo creo
que la la fortaleza como bien mencionado
usted al inicio la espina dorsal eh
seguirá siendo la economía en ese
sentido Yo creo que el equipo le va a
funcionar muy bien Ahora lo a lo que
debemos a estar atentos es que
efectivamente Y no ha pasado nunca si en
China no tendría que por qué pasar ahora
sí nunca ha existido un aparato tan
poderoso que logre contener las luchas
entre las diferentes acciones
efectivamente
en este momento vemos que el triunfo de
sí es indiscutible indisputable pero las
facciones no van a desaparecer y van a
seguir actuando aunque sea de manera
soterrada y por otra parte está la
sociedad si la sociedad se sigue
moviendo y hay zonas en movimientos
a través de los cuales la gente se sigue
expresando obviamente no son de las
dimensiones que existen en otros países
pero vamos es una sociedad muy compleja
y muy vive en ese sentido de que en el
sentido de que el poder central Nunca es
tan poderoso que logre eliminar todas
esos movimientos todas esas fuerzas
Claro que actúan en contra la
centralización claro Francisco
justamente para llevar mi siguiente
pregunta porque también es muy difícil
obtener información propia de los los
chinos si uno no conoce el idioma y no
conoce a profundidad la historia y la
forma de este pensamiento político y la
visión que ellos tienen como país como
estado y como nación en el mundo Ahí es
donde llega mi pregunta y es Eh pues uno
ve que es un único partido que rige
todos los estratos de la sociedad y a
nivel político pero usted menciona las
facciones y había entonces cierta
pluralidad dentro del partido comunista
ahora al eliminarse estas facciones en
los escaños más altos en las esferas más
altas eso no va a permitir que se
eliminen como confrontaciones con el
presidente o con sus equipos cercanos
que le permitan confrontar o por lo
menos discrepar con algunas de las ideas
y simplemente le está dando Carta blanca
para hacer lo que quieran con el país
yo creo que
vamos a ver cómo cómo evoluciona pero
ciertamente eso no no está discusiones
esa es obvio está la vista de todo el
mundo pues de quién controle el aparato
Sí desde arriba Entonces ahí decía el
triunfo del secretario general pues es
indispensable y claro pero tenemos que
ver cómo se va a desarrollar por ejemplo
la distribución del poder en las
empresas estatales este en los órganos
reguladores en fin en la diplomacia
vamos a ver es plato Cómo se dice todo
ese movimiento no bancaba las reacciones
en contra de del secretario general
decía yo van a ser pues soterradas pero
es imposible que acaben decía también
nunca ha pasado así y la otra el otro
elemento que que me gustaría poner en en
la mesa para debatir es que
esta centralización este acopio de
Prácticamente todo el poder al menos en
la intención también se expresa en en el
elemento de hacer que los chinos janes a
su puesta mayoría tenga la la hegemonía
y la homogeneidad
lingüística y cultural del país en
contra de otras expresiones lingüísticas
c y étnicas esa es una aspiración que no
la va a lograr tampoco sí y qué piensa
nuestro otro invitado Jorge en la ciudad
de Buenos Aires sobre esta falta de
pluralidad también está ausencia de
círculos reformistas al interior del
partido comunista dejaría entonces de
lado esa Esa visión de la que tanto se
habló de un socialismo al estilo chino y
pasaríamos tal vez a ver un socialismo
al estilo
bueno es el gran interrogante que se nos
presenta tras este vigésimo Congreso
Nacional del partido comunista teniendo
en cuenta que la preeminencia de un
líder único con la suma del poder
público lleva a preguntarse sobre no
solo cuál va a ser el futuro de china en
materia de política internacional sino
también puertas adentro porque uno puede
decir bueno esta facciones que han sido
licuadas estos hombres que han sido
desplazados Del Poder se van a quedar
con los brazos cruzados o como ex
miembros del establishment que
tienen poder ostentan poder van a hacer
algo al respecto entonces realmente esta
etapa que se abre genera una cierta
preocupación porque bueno tengamos
presente que estamos hablando del país
más poblado del planeta con una de las
dos economías más grandes y también con
una de las principales fuerzas armadas y
tomando el punto que recién decía el
colega Bueno del punto de vista étnico
También tenemos que tener presente que
es un país constituido por más de 55
grupos étnicos y por lo tanto entonces
cualquier afectación de su política
interna podría degenerar en
enfrentamientos y hasta una eventual
fragmentación claro es que el presidente
gobierna un país de cerca de 1400
millones de habitantes pero también dada
la importancia económica de China una
decisión que toma el presidente chilling
ping no solamente afecta china afecta al
mundo entero entonces en cierta forma es
importante entender las decisiones y el
rumbo que va a tomar este país y las
decisiones que puede tomar el presidente
justamente quería preguntarle a Jorge
por las características que tiene este
Shiny chismo o chillimpinismo como se le
pueda llamar estas características del
lo mismo que está instaurando que ha
comenzado este proceso y que parece que
lo puede llegar a consolidar en este
tercer mandato que va a comenzar para él
sí básicamente en materia de la política
interna uno de los aportes que presenta
esta nueva línea de pensamiento guarda
relación con lo que se dice la
construcción del socialismo con
peculiaridades chinas en la Nueva Era
Pero bueno Cómo se traduce esto por
ejemplo en materia económica una de sus
ideas fuerzas es el concepto de
circulación Dual esto tiene que ver que
con que no solo china va a prestar muy
importante atención a la cuestión del
comercio internacional las inversiones
En el exterior la transferencia
tecnológica el otorgamiento de créditos
sino que también va a haber una mirada
donde va a poner también en un lugar muy
importante al mercado interno
casualmente esta era una de las
preguntas que nos hacíamos cuando
veíamos el desarrollo de la política de
la reforma y apertura económica de China
es decir cuando va a tocar el papel del
mercado interno bueno con sí sin pin
gradualmente Esto está tomando forma
lo ve la palabra ahora a Francisco
Javier en México para hablar de un tema
importante es el tema del tamaño del
Estado chino del tamaño de las empresas
estatales que son sumamente grandes una
de las preocupaciones que hay es que
justamente el estado tiene que empezar a
adelgazar algunas de estas empresas Y
eso también significaría darle un poco
más de impulso a la liberación del
mercado es decir fomentar un poco más la
empresa privada Pero eso
conforme uno entiende el sistema
socialista comunista chino no sería
perder un poco de poder Precisamente en
esa aspina dorsal que es la economía
Bueno aquí hay dos elementos discursivos
que tendríamos que tomar que tomar en
cuenta el primero
según sí han sido 100 años unos primeros
100 años donde se acabó la pobreza no
hay pobreza esto se eliminó y luego
vienen otros 100 años Durante los cuales
se va a construir el socialismo Entonces
eso es esa tarea que es un debate eterno
aún antes de 1949
sobre si existe el socialismo se va a
llegar a él o no etcétera etcétera
ya está en este momento histórico está
planteado como algo para dentro de un
siglo En ese sentido debemos enmarcar el
el asunto de la economía va a ser un
avance de las fuerzas económicas
privadas Pero obviamente bajo un mayor
control del Estado porque habían
alcanzado un alto grado de libertad
hay alguna entrevista que leí hace
muchos años de del famoso jackman donde
decía perdí el miedo para decirle no al
Estado sí Entonces eso eso ya se acabó
Ya ya no no va a existir pero
realmente va a seguir el fortalecimiento
de la industria privada pero
alentando a las a las como ha sido
además en todo este proceso histórico
alentando los interés del Estado
obviamente
esté el asunto de de la adelgazamiento
de las empresas estatales no es un tema
fácil porque también ha estado presentes
de los años 80 y jamás se ha podido
lograr cabalmente yo creo que
básicamente porque el estado siempre va
a querer tener un conjunto de sectores
económicos que le sirvan claro Entonces
vamos a seguir viendo esa combinación de
sectores privados muy fuertes pero
también de sectores bajo la equidad
Estatal de Gran fortaleza esto en cuanto
al análisis más interno que podemos
hacer el tema económico que están tal
vez lo que más apasiona y más interesa
en cuanto a China escalemos lo a la
región pasemoslo al nivel las relaciones
con países vecinos es a rivalidad por el
protagonismo a nivel internacional y en
términos económicos que hay con India
por ejemplo la atención que hay con
Australia el apoyo que le da Corea del
Norte y también importante el apoyo que
le da a Rusia o por lo menos ese
respaldo o Esa
visión de taparse los ojos de en Ucrania
no pasa absolutamente nada no nos
interesa Y que Rusia haga lo que quiera
esto Cómo puede continuar la misma
posición o qué análisis pueden hacer
ustedes de lo que pueda venir para este
país Jorge
bueno en primer lugar tomando lo que has
mencionado sobre la guerra en Ucrania
efectivamente
el desarrollo de la misma está generando
un debate por lo que tengo conocimiento
al menos en el ámbito académico pero
tengamos presente que en China muchos
académicos son asesores del gobierno
central y bueno Ellos están observando
que ante la continuidad de esta
supuestamente llamada operación militar
especial de Rusia
la imagen internacional de China se está
viendo afectada porque ellos han
procurado proyectar una imagen de
hegemon benévolo es decir una potencia
pero no una potencia que afecta los
intereses de sus aliados por lo tanto
Entonces yo estimo que va a haber una
en una suerte de redefinición de la
postura de china en la materia luego
está a nivel ya más regional a mi
entender como principal idea fuerza el
desarrollo de la iniciativa de la franja
y la ruta o nueva ruta de la seda que
básicamente está dirigida a la
construcción de obras de infraestructura
para que de esa manera entonces china no
solo pueda colocar de manera más rápida
en mercados externos su producción sino
también al mismo tiempo
asegurarse el abastecimiento de materias
primas provenientes del resto de Asia y
también por supuesto África e incluso
más lejanamente de América Latina
Francisco y pasamos Esto del ámbito
regional al ámbito
internacional y es la atención que hay
en este momento entre Medellín y
Washington por el tema de Ya lo hemos
mencionado aquí varias veces esto en que
puede terminar ahora Estados Unidos está
en una coyuntura política importante hay
elecciones de medio término el
presidente biden Define Sí sí puede
continuar o no para un segundo mandato
aspirar o no esto que implicaría lo que
ya es garantizado es que sillín sigue al
mando de China quien pueda llegar en
Estados Unidos es una pregunta
la
respuesta o el conjunto de respuestas
son muy muy complejos muy complejas pero
en el sentido de que hay muchísimos
niveles de análisis el primero es la
necesidad que tiene China de un acceso
restricto al Pacífico fíjense ese ese el
acceso está restringido por todo este
digamos arco de seguridad que existes
del noreste de Asia hasta Australia
dominado por Estados Unidos le urge a
China salir lo ha estado haciendo de
manera muy puntual como un un juego de
posiciones a poder
apoderándose dilotes
acuerdos militares en fin toda una serie
de actividades que realiza
Taiwán eso desde la perspectiva china no
hay discusión Taiwán les pertenece se va
a unificar a China
y aquí Bueno pues ya entramos en el
terreno las especulaciones sobre cómo lo
harían cuando lo harían creo que en este
momento si nosotros analizamos lo que ha
pasado por ejemplo en Hong Kong no hay
un intento serio inmediato de invadir
Taiwán por muchas razones no podrían
hacerlo
la la la reacción de la población
taiwanesa no sería nada amable en fin yo
creo que eso deberíamos descartarlo por
momento la opción militar y en ese mismo
sentido tampoco creo que Estados Unidos
está interesado ahorita es el momento de
del Blog sí de de la agresión verbal eh
la negociación
yo lo que he escuchado de expertos
estadounidenses es que en Estados Unidos
no salgan que hacer si me Taiwán esa es
la realidad
y tampoco los chinos creo que tengan muy
claro eso al respecto y en ese sentido
tampoco
prioridad para los chinos en este
momento Jorge viendo algunas de las
declaraciones de el artista chino hay
way way que es un artista que era muy
cercano al gobierno
chino y tuvo que exiliarse actualmente
vive en Alemania a raíz de estos sucesos
de los últimos días ha dicho que ya
claramente el gobierno no se está
preocupando tanto por mejorar la
economía del país sino que se está
preocupando y se está enfocando en que
quieren reinterpretar el orden mundial
ustedes lo están mencionando al inicio
del programa pero aquí Entonces ve uno
que tal vez choca con con uno de sus
aliados que es Rusia porque justamente
Rusia ha justificado la invasión a
Ucrania diciendo que necesita que haya
un quiebre a nivel internacional para
forzar un nuevo orden internacional en
donde Estados Unidos es el país que
lidere en los diferentes ámbitos aquí
entonces dos aliados enfrentándose cómo
sería ese orden mundial que están
buscando los chinos
bueno China formalmente lo lo ha
plasmado en documentos oficiales hace
alusión a la necesidad de construir una
comunidad de destino compartido para la
humanidad esto En definitiva es su
proyecto de nuevo ordenamiento político
y económico internacional ellos hacen
alusión a que el actual ordenamiento
internacional
establecido desde fines de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial por Estados Unidos y sus
aliados básicamente es injusto en
materia económica en materia política
genera enfrentamientos Entonces ellos
tienen un mensaje en donde muchos
conceptos guardan relación con el
pensamiento tradicional chino de la
búsqueda de la armonía el beneficio
mutuo etcétera etcétera Pero por
supuesto nosotros analistas tenemos que
cotejar los dichos con los hechos y es
una realidad que china ha ejercido
presión militar sobre Taiwán en los
últimos tres años por lo que son las
ansias de una mayor autonomía por el
gobierno de La Isla Entonces esto genera
conjeturas genera preocupación Y por
supuesto no tenemos que olvidarnos que
detrás de Taiwán está los Estados Unidos
Porque existe desde el año
1971 la llamada acta de relaciones con
Taiwán por la cual por ley Estados
Unidos se comprometió con contribuir en
la defensa de la isla
puntualmente por favor Francisco sobre
este tema cómo sería ese orden mundial
que interpretan desde Beijing como es el
entendimiento que ellos tienen al
respecto puntual por favor
hay la intención de crear un modelo
creen que están creando un modelo que
sea atractivo para otros sociedades y
donde ellos sean una fuerza creadora de
conocimiento de educadora de recursos
humanos El ejemplo pues es ese
básicamente la es la idea que se que
está detrás del concepto de estado
civilizatorio ellos transmiten
civilización transmiten un orden de
cosas una forma de manejar la política y
la economía Esa es la la gran aspiración
dejó estos últimos minutos del programa
para analizar una imagen que llamó
muchísimo la atención a nivel
internacional y tenemos que analizar acá
y es el retiro de el ex presidente
hugging Tao de la sala cuando estaban
desarrollando allí y los debates de el
partido comunista de este congreso del
partido comunista una imagen que en
China no se vio a través de los medios
de comunicación locales solamente la
cadena internacional cgtn transmitió
algunos minutos pero la televisión
puntual no no lo transmitió que análisis
pueden hacer puntualmente Jorge por
favor
Sí como no bueno En primer término la
versión oficial que a posteriori como
has mencionado tomo conocimiento el
público guardó relación con la salud del
ex presidente Justin Tao pero nosotros
vemos en estas imágenes que la
Aparentemente no deseaba salir tampoco
vemos que haya habido empatía de sus
vecinos para ayudarlo a salir hay hasta
Incluso se llegó a decir desde la prensa
oficial china que es la posterioría
había vuelto para votar lo cual
evidenciaba que ya estaba mejor bueno
por otro lado el desde ya la otra
lectura básicamente proveniente de
occidente tenía que ver con la
existencia de una purga de una
humillación pública y digamos que
si nos basamos al menos en aquello que
nos consta es una realidad que en el
discurso
previo a este momento el criticó
duramente el mandato la década de
Juchitán así que sería darle esperar de
que haya habido alguna reacción de
Juchitán y por eso fue retirado
Francisco su opinión me queda un minuto
para terminar el programa por favor muy
puntual una escena de Gran violencia la
imposición
simbólica
del mayor poder político que alcanza así
Dentro de la dentro de las élites
dominante chinas sobre todo el
contener
a las élites anteriores decirles ya
terminó pasamos a otra era Pues a
Francisco de Jorge les agradezco mucho
por haber estado con nosotros haber
hecho este análisis para la audiencia de
Franz 24 en América Latina en nombre de
todo el equipo técnico Les agradecemos
su sintonía por haberse informado con
nosotros la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón y la
construcción de invitados a cargo de
Tania Herrera Muchas gracias por seguir
con nosotros sigan en compañía de France
[Música]